We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P you
can call anytime.
Here's an interesting question about sabotage
or sabotage depending on how you pronounce
it.
Take a listen
David, this is Dave from California.
I have a question.
Do you think Donald Trump does not want a
second term as president?
And the reason I'm asking is this is behavior,
each doing stuff and saying stuff about different
people getting rid of this person, getting
rid of that person, saying stuff about judges
and all this.
Do you think he's trying to convince the public
not to vote for him or he's just nuts?
Listen, um, I don't believe that Trump's ego
would allow him to self sabotage his a reelection
campaign.
Uh, we, we know that when Trump first ran
in the Republican primary in 2016, he didn't
think he would win and he didn't have a particular
interest in being president, but he clearly
overestimated the intelligence of a Republican
primary voters and he ended up as the nominee.
Now that he is president, I don't believe
Trump's ego would allow him to say, you know,
this is kind of a mess.
I want to go back to just eating, uh, you
know, taco salads and KFC in Trump tower and,
uh, berating window vendors on the phone to
do the deal for less money.
Uh, as, as much as that might be appealing
to him, I don't believe that his ego would
really allow him to deliberately tank his
reelection campaign.
Now, if you're saying is that, is any of this
happening subconsciously?
I guess it's conceivable that it is.
And in that case it wouldn't be something
that Trump is deliberately doing, but I don't.
Uh, no, I don't think it's a particularly
likely explanation for what we are for what
we're currently seeing.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the house passing an anti-lynching
bill and you might be wondering [inaudible]
how are they lynching they're passing that
in 2020 we will explain.
We will also talk about the Trump campaign
filing a libel lawsuit, not a lawyer lawsuit,
a libel lawsuit against the New York times
over a piece last year related to Trump and
Russia.
And lastly, we are going to talk about an
important endorsement and actual important
endorsement that Joe Biden got in South Carolina
specifically and Biden is actually looking
okay in some of the upcoming primaries, all
of those stories and much more on today's
bonus show.
Two ways to get the bonus show number one,
become a member@joinpacman.com quick, easy.
You can save 66% with the coupon code 2020
now the other way to get access to the bonus
show is become a patron
at patrion.com/david pocket show.
Either way, I will speak to you then for tomorrow
on the Friday show, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.